is there any way to work some sort of
language about a commitment towards
i'm really targeting stem and a lot of
this like everyone needs all of this but
like like
like sciences as far as like education
about like these kind of issues because
like i know like one black woman on this
campus is often like one or
one or the only like black and like
black women person in their classroom
and basically just has to sit there in
the corner and suffer through everything
and like i can find about my classes
jamil starts by saying is there any way
to word some sort of language about the
commitment towards really targeting stem
in a lot of this
when we first heard that
we were shocked
and then soon thereafter
when the protesters became rioters and
started doing both physical damage on
campus and actual um assault and battery
to students who disagreed with them
the
the places on campus that were targeted
were the library and the science labs
this uh the windows of the science labs
were broken the museum of natural
history uh was uh was vandalized and the
library was vandalized
which is exactly in keeping
with
the idea that in order to
get rid of white supremacy we need to
shut down science technology engineering
and math so
let me just say a few words about the
thing that is happening right now before
we go into more analysis this is
gizmodo's summary of the goals of
shutdown stem quote
white supremacy is baked into science
and academia from racist language and
textbooks to a culture that excludes
black scientists from innovating and
advancing at the same pace as their
colleagues but rather than more milk-toe
statements and diversity initiatives
researchers want action organizers are
asking the scientific community to
participate in a work stoppage on
wednesday june 10th to bring attention
to racism in the world of research
just asterisk
the idea that the culture of academia
and science is excluding black
scientists from innovating and advancing
is a claim for which i have seen exactly
zero evidence but it is a claim that is
being tied to the claim
that
police brutality can target
black men in particular
disproportionately for which
we do have some evidence right those
claims because they both seem to be
about racism are linked and you're not
allowed to disagree with one for fear
that you are understood to be
disagreeing with the other this is from
the actual shutdown stem website those
of us who are not black particularly
those of us who are white play a key
role in perpetuating systemic racism
direct actions are needed to stop this
injustice unless you engage directly
with eliminating racism you're
perpetuating it this moment calls for
profound change
shut down shutdown academia and hashtag
shutdown stem is the time for white and
non-black people of color this is a new
acronym to me nbpoc non-black people of
color to not only educate themselves but
to define a detailed plan of action to
carry forward
and wednesday june 10th will mark that
day okay so we can take that down
that's one more thing
the uh the we are beginning to see uh
the movement splinter into its
constituent parts these are all uh
screenshots of tweets from the last day
or two this is nature magazine one of
the two biggest most important
preeminent science journals in the world
saying that they are going to be joining
shut down stem
striking for black lives is the is the
one of the taglines that
people have become convinced this is
what it's about uh next from science the
editor-in-chief of science says science
and scientists must say out loud they
have benefited from and failed to
acknowledge white supremacy
next one of many societies um
professional societies this happens to
be the society for research and child
development
is saying shut down academia and uh
genuflecting before the new gods
four
we have some academics with their
version of well what they actually say
is looking forward to shut down stem and
having conversations with my students
tomorrow about racism and academia
as folks who hold any power in academia
is our responsibility to disrupt the
system and take responsibility for
ongoing contributions to systemic
oppression
i read this as don't hurt me please move
along nothing to see here
five
this craziness from an academic hot tip
to lee jessum for pointing this out to
me i hope there are a lot of circles in
academia having serious conversation on
how academic freedom upholds white
supremacy racism and prejudice
yup and finally uh six we have a phd
student
zachary six
saying um i can't read that um
i'm not sure what it says among other
things she says the science can wait
because obviously
in the middle of a global pandemic
the science can wait
well they have taken pains they have
learned from the accusation that there's
something
untoward about mass protests when we
should be social distancing and so they
have taken pains to exclude work on
covet 19
from their she didn't even at first
though they've added that
maybe they got some immediate pushback
there's a bunch to say here but i really
think the most important thing we can do
and we have to make sure to do a good
job of it before we're done here today
is to give people a sense for what they
are actually seeing because almost all
of this is euphemistic and not
straightforward it's potemkin it's not
to be taken at face value and frankly
um
there there are two experiences for us
that are happening simultaneously on the
one hand we are having a large number of
people wake up to the fact that what
they saw happen to us at evergreen is
part of something much larger as we
tried to warn them
and so on the one hand that's reassuring
that at least we are not in a tiny group
of people who see it many more people
are seeing it this week than last for
example
but there is also
this
uh increasingly frustrating sense
that we lived through this in order
to
make it possible to avoid having this
takeover civilization in other words i
feel like we paid a high price at least
in terms of our security in the world we
were tossed into a completely unknown
realm and we are still there we're doing
fine but
we had 10-year jobs now
we're here on the internet trying to
figure out what our new job is right
so
in some sense this was all for naught
we went through this we you know we
we had the police withdrawn from a riot
against us and we watched the community
patrols descend immediately into
violence we know what happens when you
uh when you shut down the police
and i must say as much as it was
surprising to see jamil talking so
openly and on camera about his feeling
that stem was the problem
i can't remember the first instance but
somewhere in the year prior to
evergreen's meltdown i remember it may
have been in a faculty meeting i
remember
saying something about
that what was unfolding was a challenge
to enlightenment values and that we
academics had an obligation to defend
them and i remember being stunned
to hear an attack on enlightenment
values come back right not just the
enlightenment right but enlightenment
values
and
you know at first i was which i
understand to be
rigor and logic in combination with
compassion for the humanity of all
people right you know maybe that's a
sort of strictulato that's a really
broad interpretation and a more narrow
interpretation is just maybe about logic
and rigor and uh and using science to
understand what we do in the world but
um even so even so those are the values
that you're fighting back against
it was stunning to me i did i didn't
think anybody could marshal such a
broken argument in public and not have
you know a faculty assembled for a
faculty meeting erupt in people saying
wait no you don't have that right you
haven't understood what enlightenment
values are then because you couldn't
possibly be attacking them but it was
just silence right
and people are scared
that is the thing people need to
understand is that at some level we've
said in other contexts
that frequently you will understand what
people are doing
better
if you turn down the sound because we
humans can't help but process language
and if you listen to what people say
they are doing
then you will often be misled if what
they are doing is not the same thing and
so you have lots of people who are
saying that they are looking forward to
talking about bias in the sciences
okay there's nothing wrong with talking
about bias in the sciences it exists and
it has a long and
dark history agreed but certainly
certainly up through the end of the 19th
century it was a prime it was actually a
primarily not just white and male
endeavor but also sort of a landed white
and male difference it was it was for it
was rich people and those rich people
tended to be men and those rich people
tended to be white and um you know what
has happened in the 20th century in part
is an opening up um
across all of those demographic
categories and you know obviously i have
benefited from it being open to women
but i think more so the va like everyone
effectively who's doing science today
has benefited from it no longer being
just uh appropriate for the landed
gentry right um this is this is now
actually open to to anyone there's a
move away from that now we've talked a
little bit about the problems in modern
science before but
the fact that
in theory
you can get yourself into college and
get through and become a scientist no
matter where you came from
is wholly different from anything that
was true of the western scientific
tradition up until
i don't know at least the turn of the
19th to 20th century yeah the door is
wide open which doesn't mean people are
walking through it in numbers that are
proportional to their numbers in the
population and sure it's certainly worth
talking about why that isn't the case
and what might be done about it i think
it would be wonderful if people did show
up in numbers that were proportional but
nonetheless
if you're scratching your head if this
is the first time you've heard
enlightenment values challenged or i
mean
please understand
shut down stem
is a new
kind of tactic
i tried to get somebody to tell me if
this tactic had a name and a lot of
people came up with things that were in
the ballpark but nobody has come up with
a description the thing about shut down
stem and it works the same way for uh
defund the police is that these terms
are basically a floating point variable
shutdown stem could mean what
people presumably at science think
they're doing when they use their
uh platform to broadcast this stuff that
we are shutting down for a day
symbolically to acknowledge that there's
been some bias right
but
how imagine that you were sitting
somewhere and you thought how can we
demonstrate our power
let's get the very top echelon of
science to broadcast
shutdown stem right and then you realize
that those same people who
seek this kind of power are also
actually broadcasting the message that
science itself is the problem that i
mean you heard their language that
white supremacy is baked in
baked into science think about how
preposterous a claim this is right
scientific method you observe a pattern
you hypothesize a possible explanation
you come up with some predictions that
would be true if the hypothesis was
correct and then you run a test right
but they're pretending that the
scientific method is something like you
observe a pattern
you come up with some explanation that
blames black people and then you
broadcast it without checking right now
has has science been done badly a lot
sure absolutely has some of that bad
science been done badly in service of
racist goals yes is that happening in
the last 20 years
i don't see any evidence of it and
and and we've gone looking eventually
50 years even right and that's not to
say that this isn't pretty recent
history
and that there hasn't been a lot of
frankly evil done
in the guise of in the uniform of
science but that doesn't make it science
but just just like
black lives matter
is cloaking itself in something that
sounds honorable and amazing and is not
actually that inside
the idea that eugenics or social
darwinism is actually a scientific uh a
scientific study it's not it's the it's
the same misapprehension but even if it
was let's transport ourselves back
50 or 100 years
right
the cure for bad science is good science
and it always has been science is a bias
correction mechanism that's really the
only thing it does you don't need
science to tell you things that are
obvious you need science to tell you
things that are counterintuitive which
means that whatever your biases are
science is the tool for
addressing them and i would say further
let's imagine so if you listen to the
leaders of the movement and you listen
to what their internal conversation
sounds like they say look
white supremacy is so baked in that you
have to level the institution and
replace it with something else and
sometimes they will say something
afro-centric right
now let's suppose for a moment that
there was some other system that was
interested in what's true that's what
science is about what's true
and it was self-correcting which is the
beauty of science the thing that
separates it from every other method
let's suppose that you did have an
alternative method all the better if it
comes from africa lovely okay so you've
got some other method that is both
self-correcting and interested in the
truth
what will happen to it if you set it in
motion it will converge on enlightenment
science that's what it'll do so at this
point in a global economy it will and we
know that there have been other
enlightenments you know the
enlightenment that we talk about when we
refer to it is the european
enlightenment um but the maya as we have
talked about before the maya had an
enlightenment many hundreds of years
before the europeans did
and um although we know very little
about what their inner workings of their
thinking was because almost their entire
library was destroyed in fact by the
spaniards when they arrived
although the maya themselves were
already a culture and decline at the
point that the spaniards arrived
what we do know is that they had
astronomers they had scribes they had a
concept of zero they had mathematics
they had um vast written literature um
they had
they had they had an enlightenment
advanced agricultural chemistry
so
i don't even want to put caveats on it
though you need two characteristics to
guarantee that all you have to add is
time before you rediscover science right
it doesn't matter what the nature of a
truth-seeking self-correcting mechanism
is it will inevitably land there and
what that means is that the right thing
to do if you really want to empower
black people and believe me i do if you
really want to do that the
best thing you can do is you can arm
them with the tools of science rather
than setting us back hundreds of years
and waiting for some other method to
converge on discoveries we've already
got you can arm them you can democratize
these tools which is exactly what we
were doing at evergreen it is exactly
why they had to come for us now this is
the part that i think people are going
to be totally bewildered by why if this
movement is so interested in empowering
black people would it attack a tool that
was really their best weapon in order to
end whatever oppression remains
and here's the reason
this movement isn't what it looks like
this movement is a false version of
something that doesn't exist to be found
in large numbers in other words the
energy has been captured by people who
are not well intentioned and the reason
that they hate science is because
science is a good mechanism for figuring
out what's true and what they are
peddling is not true
so the last thing they want is people
empowered to check their claims because
their claims don't stand up and we saw
this all over the evergreen debacle
right when we said okay you're telling
us that there is racism
at evergreen
where's the evidence and what did they
say they said to ask for evidence of
racism is racism with a capital r now
that's obviously a preposterous circular
bit of logic but the idea even more
precisely to ask for evidence of racism
is evidence of racism yep
so it's inescapable it's hermetically
sealed by design so now think about what
you've seen you've seen
tens of thousands of people in the
street marching behind banners that seem
superficially like they might be pointed
in the direction of something good but
are actually trojan horses hiding
something else most of them don't know
they're carrying trojan horses i don't
think they have no idea yeah and even
the ones so you point to some of the
tweets that people are you said that
they are basically saying don't hurt me
that's certainly a component of it but
there's something far more insidious
here
when these people
they see the mob coming they look at
their skin they say uh oh i don't want
to be backed against the wall and they
figure out what you have to say in order
not to get back to get into the wall to
get the mob to move on to somebody else
a they are externalizing harm onto the
next person right they have an
obligation to stand up and by not
standing up they make the mob stronger
and then the next person backs against
the wall has an even bigger problem
right so this is not cool but
the worst part of it and we've seen it
hundreds of times
is the individual
says this thing to get the mob to leave
them alone and then they've got a
problem
how the hell are you gonna sleep after
you've done that right so what do they
do
they tell themselves that it's true
right they forget what they knew and
they tell themselves this is actually
the the right thing that's why i did it
and so now the point is
the mob didn't just
move on it actually captured their minds
right
now the reason that people like us
were so animated after the evergreen
meltdown was that we saw this force take
over lots and lots of people who should
know better and after it took them over
there was no place there was no place
that you could say it stops here which
is why i said in that clip what i said
it's why i said the same thing to
congress
right this is going to eventually spill
over into anything now
truth be told i'm impressed at the speed
um but nonetheless the mechanism was
obvious and
um
well anyway it's it is very important
that you think what is the most
parsimonious explanation for what i'm
seeing is this an honest confusion about
whether science is a good thing or is
this a demonstration of power
[Music]